how long do you think it will take the
drill through the surface of Europa
assuming we get a man-made object on its
surface and do you think there could be
any kind of complex life living under
the ice excellent question
in fact Europa if you didn't otherwise
know is one of the moons of Jupiter and
Jupiter is way far out of the Goldilocks
zone that we talk about yeah where
you're not too close to the Sun
otherwise if you had water that would
evaporate not too far away otherwise if
you had water it would freeze and life
as we know it thrives on liquid water
earth is in the habitable zone the
Goldilocks zone of the Sun Jupiter is
not mmm yet Europa one of Jupiter's
moons which is icy on its surface is
kept warm by the gravitational stress
that Jupiter brings to bear on it
and it squeezes the planet the orb in
ways that if you hit a racquetball you
never or if you play any other racquet
sports they say let's get up the ball
before we play you hit the ball the ball
recoils back into shape you hit it again
every time you hit it you're pumping
energy into the ball and the ball
physically literally gets warmer Jupiter
is trying to stress the physical shape
of Europa as it orbits the planet and
it's in a tug of war between the gravity
of Jupiter and the gravity of other
moons around Jupiter and so the shape of
Europa is changing ever so slightly but
it's doing that constantly and it is
pumping energy into Europa what would
otherwise be a frozen body in the outer
solar system has is liquid water deep
beneath the frozen surface how deep is
the surface we think it's about a
kilometer thick a little more than a
half a mile and so that's thick and
that's so so that is very drillable I
mean I could drill that if I had a ha
one kilometer long drill and a lot of
time Sochi spacesuits she wants to know
how long would take a human to do this a
human would probably not be the first
attempt to get through that ice right
you you send a bunch of cats that you
would teach how to dig so you'd send
something that could possibly melt a
hole through it you can send for example
a radioactive ball that has its own
source menu it's on a tether and the
ball drops through the ice as it melts
down brings the tether with it and then
it opens up a little camera lens when it
gets down to the bottom so that would be
fun and what are the chances of finding
life there I am um I'm a life fan for
Europa because it's been liquid water
for billions of years right in any place
on earth we find liquid water we find
life even the Dead Sea that's just a
statement of is there is there life in
the Dead Sea they just didn't have a
microscope it's the kind of life they
knew anything about you know it's not
there's no fish and no kid there's no
it's the two most common forms of life
are fish and children but there's
microbes yeah so in a lot of skin
softening agents any intervals
apparently so any place we found liquid
where we found life so if order has this
sort of magic property that it
stimulates the formation of life in the
presence of the right other ingredients
you rope us surely a candidate for this
and it opens up our concept of where to
look for life in the galaxy because this
is outside of the Goldilocks zone with a
source of energy not dependent on the
Sun itself so it's it's own Goldilocks
zone based on stress now it's it's own
little Goldilocks zone
how hard would it be to get there to
send some sort of radioactive ball on a
spaceship there we've we've been there
already and I've already had Landers all
we had to do is add a radioactive ball
to it well and you have designed it to
do it right and to know and by the way
what if you're wondering if there's life
there that ice actually cracks and the
water seeps up through the ice and
refreezes so it's been suggested that
there might be sort of freeze dried fish
in near the surface in the cracks
between the ice if we brought that back
and ate it would we die right away or in
a week we would but you could probably
sell it for like a gazillion dollars eat
your rope of food and what would you
call life on Europa both Europeans yeah
I would yeah and then people in Europe
would be furious um